Guten Abend.
Also meine Name ist Eiloghan. Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt für Sie und würde gerne mit Ihnen was an einem Nasegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir ja.
Also ich werde zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Dann kommen wir sofort auch zu Ihren Beschwörden.
Ja, ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Friedrich Schneider.
Also Friedrich schreibt sich F-R-I-E-D.
D-D-D-R-I-C-H, ein Männername.
Sehr okay. Und Schneider?
Schneider, S-C-H-N-A-E-I-D-E-R, Schneider.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 10.10.50.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin 1,76.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
89 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, ich nicht. Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch bin.
Super, perfekt.
Also wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Das ist Frau Dr. Krüger.
Frau Dr. Krüger.
Mit U-U-Maut, ja?
Ja, genau.
Okay. Also was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Schneider? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche Schmerzen in meinem rechten Bein.
Und ich meine, ich habe da schon lange Schmerzen im Unterschenkel.
Aber seit drei Tagen ist es wirklich ganz viel schlimmer geworden.
Und jetzt sind die Schmerzen mit einmal auch im Oberschenkel.
Und ich kann fast überhaupt gar nicht mehr laufen.
Also wissen Sie, ich habe ein Hund und gehe mit ihm immer spazieren.
Und früher konnte ich mit dem richtig lange Spazieren gehen,
ohne dass ich irgendwelche Beschwerden hatte.
Also ein Kilometer war überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Und dann hat das angefangen, ja, dass mir die Strecke ein bisschen zu lang wurde.
Und jetzt seit ein paar Tagen, seit drei Tagen hat es angefangen,
jetzt kann ich mal gerade 100 Meter gehen.
Und dann muss ich stehen bleiben, weil mein Bein so schrecklich weh tut.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Also, könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Also sind Sie eher dumm, stichend, bedennt? Wie würden Sie?
Nee, eher drückend und, ja, starker Druck.
Und sie werden halt immer schlimmer, als es wird, überhaupt nicht besser.
Na ja, gut, Schmerzen hat man mal.
Aber das wird eben immer mehr.
Und wie gesagt, jetzt ist es mit einmal bis oben in den Oberschenkel rein.
Also, könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau lokalisieren?
Also sind Sie im Badebereich oder vor der Seite?
Wie würden Sie sagen?
Vielleicht, ja, also in der rechten Bade sind Sie auf alle Fälle im Unterschenkel, ja.
Aber jetzt sind Sie eben auf, wie gesagt, im Oberschenkel.
Okay, die Schmerzen strahlen in den Oberschenkel aus, ja?
Nein, jetzt sind die Schmerzen jetzt auch im Oberschenkel.
Am Anfang waren Sie nur im rechten Unterschenkel und jetzt sind Sie im ganzen Bein.
Okay, das ist klar.
Und jetzt sind Sie so heftig, dass ich eben überhaupt nicht mehr gehen kann.
Okay, also wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskoller,
wobei ein sehr leichter und zehn sehr starke Schmerzen im Sprich?
Oh, ja, also wenn ich, wenn ich versuche, weiter zu laufen,
dann sind die Schmerzen sicherlich bei sieben oder so.
Also jedenfalls deutlich über der Mitte, würde ich sagen, ja.
Also, haben Sie Schmerzen auch in Ruhe?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Nein, das ist immer nur, wenn ich loslaufen.
Okay, also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie, also 100 Meter lang ohne Schmerzen laufen können.
Ja, genau, genau. Jetzt kann ich nur noch 100 Meter laufen, genau.
Noch 100 Meter? Müssen Sie eine Pause machen?
Dann muss ich stehen bleiben, ja.
Und dann ist es wirklich krass, ja.
Dann muss ich im Moment warten und dann kann ich, aber den dreh ich schon wieder um,
dann gehen wir schon wieder nach Hause, weil es einfach nicht weitergeht.
Also, nach der Pause sind die Schmerzen weg, oder?
Na ganz weg sind die da nicht, aber so, dass ich wieder weitergehen kann.
Also, haben Sie Schwellung bemerkt am Bein?
Das habe ich nicht gesehen, aber so genau habe ich mir das nicht angeguckt.
Aber was ich bemerkt habe, dass ich das ein bisschen, also, ja,
das es so kribbelt und das es ein bisschen so taub sich anfühlt in dem Bein.
Und bisschen kribbelt, haben Sie gedacht, ja?
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Rötung bemerkt oder irgendwelche Faltveränderungen?
Das habe ich nicht gesehen, also, das habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Also, hatten Sie damals, ich meine pro drei Tagen, einen Unfall?
Nein, da ist nichts passiert, ich habe mich nicht gestoßen oder bin nicht hingefallen oder so.
Nee, da war nichts.
Also, sind die Schmerzen rüstlich aufgetreten?
Ja, dass das jetzt mit einmal so viel schlechter ist, das ist jetzt plötzlich gekommen, genau.
Haben Sie Überwarmung bemerkt am Bein?
Was habe ich bemerkt?
Überwarmung.
Also, Warmesgefühl am Bein?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, also, haben Sie schon mal ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt oder ist das erst mal?
Das ist zum ersten Mal, wie gesagt, ich bin ja bisher immer mit meinem Hund gelaufen und da hatte ich nie Probleme.
Super.
Also, haben Sie Ruskelkraftverlust?
Kraftverlust, ich meine.
Ja, also, das ist ja jetzt erst seit ein paar Tagen.
Also, ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich weniger Kraft habe, sondern das ist einfach so schmerzhaft, dass ich nicht mehr gehen kann.
Also, haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fiebrig verschlechend?
Nein, nein, ich nicht. Nein, ich fühle mich fiebrig nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Überkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, nein, mein Bein tut mir weh.
Also, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Ich wieg mich nicht so oft, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich abgenommen habe oder auch zugenommen.
Die Hosen sitzen immer noch stramm, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhl gehabt?
Ja, in meinem Alter hat man natürlich schon mal ein bisschen Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Nachts muss ich wohl manchmal raus, ja.
Aber mit dem Stuhlgang habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Wie viel mal müssen Sie in der Nacht auch die Toilette geben?
Also, meistens einmal, manchmal auch zweimal.
Also, haben Sie deswegen beim Yerologen kontrollieren lassen?
Ja, ich bin natürlich regelmäßig beim Hausarzt, ne?
Und der guckt immer nach mir.
Und beim Yerologen bin ich auch einmal gewesen, aber damals war alles in Ordnung.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich, wenn die Prost hat, hat er ein bisschen vergrößert.
Das ist nun mal so.
Also, seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme, also Wasserlassen-Probleme?
Boah, das habe ich schon lange, bestimmt fünf, sechs Jahre.
Okay.
Sind Sie deswegen in Behandlung?
Nein, nein.
Nein, das ist ja nur das.
Also, ich bin so regelmäßig in Behandlung wegen meiner anderen Geschichten,
was ich so habe.
Ich habe halt so so ein Alterszucker und der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch.
Und ich hatte auch vor 15 Jahren, hat man mir mein Stent ins Herz gesetzt.
Und deswegen muss ich halt regelmäßig Medikamente nehmen
und bin auch regelmäßig bei meinem Hausarzt, ja.
Okay.
Herr Schneider.
Also, haben Sie Stilfgroße oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Herr Schneider, ich würde nun einfach fragen, zu Ihrer Folge gestell.
Leiden Sie an Kronschenerkrankungen?
Da habe ich ja gerade gesagt, dass ich also so ein Alterszucker habe
und dann nehme ich halt net Formientabletten ein.
Also, ich meine, außerhalb Alterszucker oder also Postata,
haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, der Blutdruck ist eben ein bisschen zu hoch.
Und dann eben diese Herzgeschichte,
dass man mir da vor 15 Jahren diesen Stent angesetzt hat.
Vor 15 Jahren.
Seit wann haben Sie Zugerkrankheit?
Ja, das hat man dann so vor 10 Jahren festgestellt.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, das reicht ja wohl hin.
Also, mir reicht es völlig, ja.
Ja, klar.
Also, sind Sie schon einmal ok?
Nein, mein ganzes Leben habe ich doch keine Operation gehabt.
Also, außer dieser Stent-Operation.
Aber das ist ja keine richtige Operation gewesen, ne?
Ja, ich denke, super.
Also, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie gegen Zugerkrankheit
regelmäßig Metformin einnehmen.
Morgen und Abend, ja.
Morgen und Abend. Wie viele Gramm nehmen Sie?
Oh, ich glaube, da steht 800 oder 850 drauf, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Alles klar.
Was doof nehmen Sie, regeln Sie sich ein oder beide da?
Ja, ich nehme noch Klopidogrel jeden Morgen.
Und Aspirin nehme ich auch noch.
Das ist, glaube ich, wegen dieses Dent.
Und dann nehme ich abends noch eine Tablette, die heißt Simvastatin.
Simvastatin.
Okay, also, Sie haben errübte Blutverpärte, ja.
Ja, ich glaube, deswegen wisst das, ja.
Also, kennen Sie die Dosierung Klopidogrel, Aspirin oder Simvastatin?
Ja, Aspirin ist ja immer 100, ne?
Und Klopidogrel ist, da steht, glaube ich, 75 drauf.
Und bei Simvastatin steht 20 drauf.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, also, ich finde auch, dass das ziemlich viel ist,
schon, was ich nehme.
Viel verschiedene Sachen regelmäßig, ja.
Ja, stimmt.
Herr Schneider, was brauchen Sie?
Ja, also, ich habe früher mal geraucht, ja.
Aber nie so richtig viel.
Okay, also, seit wann haben Sie mich mit dem Raubchen aufgehört?
Ja, vielleicht, also, muss ich mal überlegen.
Als ich, als das anfing, als das anfing mit dem Herzen, also vor 15 Jahren,
da habe ich das ungefähr aufgehört.
Also, haben Sie früher, also wie viele Jahre haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ich habe bestimmt 40 Jahre geraucht, ja.
40 Jahre, also durchschnittlich wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie nicht.
Also, bestimmt zwischen 10 und 15, würde ich sagen, ja.
Also, wenn viel los war, auch mal ein ganzes Päckchen am Tag,
aber meistens nur so 10 Stück am Tag oder so.
Okay, okay.
Ziemlich werden Sie Alkohol, Herr Schneider?
Ja, nicht mehr so viel.
Früher habe ich ein bisschen mehr getrunken, aber jetzt nur noch gelebend.
Wenn ich alleine bin, trinke ich nicht so gerne etwas.
Aber wenn mal Freunde zu Besuch kommen oder wenn es mal irgendwas zu feiern gibt,
dann trinke ich auch gerne mal ein bisschen Alkohol, ja.
Also, was trinken Sie, wenn Sie etwas trinken möchten?
Bier trinke ich gerne und ja, wenn es auch mal Schnaps dazu gibt,
finde ich das auch ganz gut.
Okay, Herr Schneider, nehmen Sie bitte nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, nee, in meinem Alter, nee, nee, da bin ich zu alt dafür.
So was mache ich nicht, nee, nee.
Ich habe die jungen Leute unter sich ausregeln, ja.
Perfekt, das freut mich.
Also, wer ist Ihre Eltern noch?
Ach, hören Sie, ich bin 74, meine Eltern sind schon lange tot.
Woran sind Sie bestritten?
Ach, mein Vater, der hatte schon früh in Herzenfakt und meine Mutter,
ja, die ist auch nicht alt geworden, die hatte dann irgendwie eine Trombose
und hatte dann eine Lungeemboli und dann ist sie mit einmal gestorben, ja.
Also, Sie hat diese Trombose am Wein?
Ich meine, ja, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Schneider?
Nein, ich bin Verwittwitt.
Verwittwitz.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, wir hatten keine Kinder.
Ich habe nur noch meinen Hund, mit dem lebe ich zusammen.
Also, sind Sie, Sie sind jetzt in Ruhe stand, ja?
Ja, ja, natürlich, ich kann nicht mehr arbeiten.
Also, also, also, haben Sie für was gemacht?
Also, als wirklich, ich meine.
Dass ich beruflich gemacht habe?
Ich war viele Jahre Gastwirt.
Gastwirt?
Mhm.
Ich habe in einem Restaurant, also eine Kneipe gehabt, ja, wo man was trinken konnte
und wo die Leute abends gekommen sind, wo es kleine, kleinem Speisen gab.
Da habe ich immer in meiner, in meiner Kneipe gestanden
und habe da die Leute bewirtet.
Wie er ausgesenkt.
Mhm.
Okay, ich möchte, also Herr Schneider, ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Ah, also, okay, also, ich habe etwas, also ich habe vergessen, etwas zu fragen.
Ich möchte jetzt zu unserer, also, ihre aktuelle Bechwertung zuhübsch bekommen.
Also, haben Sie Luftnot?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Arten.
Ich habe nur, ich habe nur diese wahnsinnigen Schmerzen im Bein.
Nein, okay.
Haben Sie Herzdasein oder Herzstolpe?
Nein, mit meinem Herzen, das ist ja alles wieder gut.
Okay, okay, super, das wollte ich auch.
Also, jetzt, ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie ab, ob Sie?
Ich habe so viel erzählt, Sie wissen ja schon alles über mich.
Ja, ich würde mal, also, das mich natürlich jetzt interessiert.
Was können wir gegen diese Schmerzen machen und wie kann ich wieder laufen?
Ich muss mich ja selber versorgen.
Und wenn ich nicht richtig laufen kann, kann ich ja auch nicht einkaufen gehen und gar nichts.
Mhm.
Ja, ich verstehe Herr Schneider, also ich kann Ihnen zurzeit nicht so viel sagen.
Ich muss erst mal sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann Bullot abnehmen, werde ich Bullot abnehmen, dann ein paar Maßnahmen durchschütteln, zum Beispiel die Kontrasteil am Bein.
Tut es weh?
Nein, nein, das ist Schmerzfreies, Herr Paren.
Okay, ja, dann ist gut.
Es ist auch sehr sicher, keine starren Belastung.
Das ist gut.
Und also nach den Ergebnissen kann ich Ihnen mehr sagen, was Sie genau haben.
Okay, ja.
Dann ich werde Sie Schritt für Schritt, Schritt für Schritt informieren.
Das klingt gut. Ja, vielen Dank.
Wir haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ich habe für Sie eine Frage, wenn es geht.
Und wachen Sie am Nacht vor Schmerzen auf?
Direkt aufwachen nicht, ich wache höchstens wegen der, weil ich zur Toilette muss auf.
Aber ich schlafe nicht so gut zur Zeit, ja, das ist schon richtig.
Aber ich wache nicht wegen Schmerzen auf.
Okay, zweite Frage ist, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Flugreise oder eine Reise ohne Bewegung gewacht?
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe keine Reise gemacht.
Danke.
Ja, deine Frage?
Bitte.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verschlimmen, vor allem da zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel Tieflagerung, Hochlagerung?
Also ja, was hilft, gegen die Schmerzen des Stehen bleiben?
Und was die Schmerzen schlimmer macht, ist, ja, natürlich irgendwie anstrengend laufen.
Also langsam laufen geht, ganz langsam laufen geht.
Und im Bedarfsfall dann eben stehen bleiben.
Und wenn ich jetzt versuche, eine Treppe hochzulaufen, dann muss ich schon ganz schnell stehen bleiben, weil es weh tut.
Das ist also das, was Ruhe tut gut und Belastung macht Schmerzen.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hat sich die Haut in diesem Bereich verändert?
Ja, mir ist das schon aufgefallen, dass da immer so viele Schuppen sind in meinem Badezimmer, dass die Haut so schuppig geworden ist.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Ja, und beim Duschen, dass ich mir da immer die Hand sucht, so diese Hautschuppen runterrubbeln.
Medikament gefragt, dagegen nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Wogegen?
Wogegen.
Gegen die Schmerzen habe ich keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Ich habe nur meine üblichen Medikamente eingenommen.
Diese Fragen stirbt oder nicht gestärkt?
Die hat ja nicht gestellt.
Ob ich wegen der Schmerzen noch irgend ein Medikament genommen habe, hat er tatsächlich nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie Kolostriere Probleme?
Ja, ich glaube, das hat der Doktor ja gerade gesagt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, wie viel das in der Tatin ist, aber es scheint ja so etwas zu sein, das doch so gut ist.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestattet können wir als Herzgespräch anfangen.
Guten Abend Frau Oberresten.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie gute Zeit für mich?
Ja natürlich, wer haben Sie denn gesehen?
Herr Friedrich Schneider ist ein 74-jähriger Patient, 1,76 m groß und 89 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellte sich heute wegen druckender, zunehmender Beinschmerzen rechts bei Uslo.
Jetzt haben wir ein Verbindungsproblem, da kann sie nicht mehr hören und ihr Bild steht.
Jetzt hoffen wir, dass er selber merkt, dass irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Hallo Esma.
Eben hat es doch alles noch geklappt, so eine Gemeinheit.
Aha, er macht ein Neustart. Meistens ist das das einzige, das hilft, dass man noch einmal neu anfängt.
Ich denke, bei der FSB sagen wir, dass der Recht unter der Extremität am besten ist.
Ja, wir machen manöverkritik gleich.
Hallo Esma, bitte schön.
Jetzt haben wir Sie wieder. Haben Sie gemerkt, wann Sie ausgestiegen sind?
Der steht schon wieder, ne?
Ja.
Jetzt bewegt er sich. Jetzt können wir etwas hören und sehen.
Okay, also ich fange jetzt an.
Ja, machen Sie nochmal bitte.
Okay, also Herr Friedrich Schneider stierte sich heute wegen seit drei Tagen bestehender, druckender, zunehmender Beinschmerzen rechts bei Uslo.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen am Anfang im Oberschenkel waren, aber dann im Laufe der Zeit haben die Schmerzen nach Oberschenkel gezogen.
Also am Anfang waren sie im Unterschenkel?
Ja, eben haben die Oberschen gezogen, aber jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Also der Patient berichtete, dass er 100 Meter lang ohne Schmerzen laufen kann.
Seit wann?
Seit drei Tagen.
Okay, und vorher?
Also vorher hatte er keine Probleme.
Okay.
Die Schmerz in den Städten wurde mit sieben von zehn auch eine Schmerz konzentriertet.
Wie nennt man denn dieses Phänomen, wenn jemand stehen bleiben muss und die Schmerzen, damit die Schmerzen weggehen?
Ich genie das nicht, leider.
Claudicatio Intermittens?
Ja.
Mhm, okay.
Also Herr Schneide klagte über Hypo- und Parästhesie auf.
Auf Nachfrage wurden ödeime, also Rötung, Bewahrung, verneint.
Also er hat diese Beschwerden erst mal gehabt.
Mhm.
Dann in der Vegetativanahmese weitet er an Nukri.
Also ein bis zweimal muss er auch getreuert gehen in den Nachbarn.
Deswegen hat er Schlafstörungen.
Also bekannte Erkrankungen sind Diabetes mellitus, zu zweit seit zehn Jahren.
Arterielechipertone seit 15 Jahren.
Und Corona-Herzkrankheit auch seit 15 Jahren.
Und Benin, Kostatik, Periplasie seit fünf bis sechs Jahren.
Also vor 15 Jahren wurde bei den Patienten ein Stent vorgenommen.
Wo?
Also im Herz.
Corona-Stent, okay.
Ja, Corona-Herzkrankheit.
Ja, okay.
Also er nimmt regelmäßig Metformin ab 150 mg, zweimal, also einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Und Klopidogrel 75 mg, einmal morgens.
Und Sinastatin 20 mg, einmal abends.
Und Assefil Saliseriksohre einmal.
Also 100 mg einmal.
Ah, ja, okay.
Wegen des Herzens wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ja, stimmt.
Also er ist seit 15 Jahren nicht rauch her.
Aber früher hat er 40 Jahre lang täglich 10 bis 15 Zigaretten geraucht.
Also wir haben hier 20 Peggitschir.
Ja.
In der Familienanamnese ergab bei der Mutter also Lungenembolie.
Und bei dem Vater, also sein Vater ist am Herzenpark verstorben.
Okay.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er ist verwidert und hat keine Kinder.
Also er ist jetzt Rentner.
Früher hat er in einem Kiosk gearbeitet.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Also nach den anonystischen Angaben habe ich einen Perspektiv
für die Arterie der Verschmutzkrankheit.
Was könnte es alternativ sein?
Alternativ kommen Ersippel und also tieffähne Thrombose.
Es kann auch Wandscheiberprophal sein.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Das sind eigentlich die klassischen Differenzialdiagnose.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit den Patienten?
Also erst mal werde ich körperliche Unterdrückungen machen.
Worauf achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung bei diesen Patienten?
Also ich muss die perfekte Arterie, dass es kurs gibt.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel Arterie dorsalis pedis und zeviens posterior.
Sehr gut.
Und nur auf der rechten Seite?
Nein, ich taste beide Seiten.
Seitens Vergleich, genau.
Sehr gut.
Okay, was machen Sie noch?
Also der Patient hat gesagt, dass er keine Schwellung und Rötung haben.
Aber das überprüfen Sie noch einmal.
Das überprüfen Sie bei unserer Suchung.
Ja, ich finde, also...
Und wonach gucken Sie noch?
Also wir haben ein paar Zeichen für die TfT.
Also ich überprüfe diese Zeichen.
Waren Sie mal ein Beispiel?
Also zum Beispiel Maya Zeichen, Paya Zeichen.
Maya Paya Homa, ne?
Ja, Homa Zeichen.
Ja, sehr schön.
Gut, okay.
Ja, worauf achten Sie noch allein vom Aspekt her?
Wenn Sie das Bein angucken oder die Beine?
Also zum Beispiel bei der Institution,
wölfe ich die Wunde zum Beispiel?
Ja, genau.
Und was noch?
Parfellinogen zum Beispiel.
Ja, genau.
Ja, oder Blässe.
Ja, Blässe, stimmt.
Und Sie tasten, was?
Außer den Fußpulsen?
Das fühlen Sie noch?
Also ich überprüfe die Sine.
Also die Sensen...
Aha, Sie machen einen neurologischen Test.
Ja, genau.
Er hat es auch bei dem Test gefühlt.
Also die Prostisie, Parastisie.
Er hat eher so gesagt, aber...
Das müssen Sie noch überprüfen.
Ja, aber im Moment müssen wir das überprüfen.
Ja, es kam gerade der Hinweis,
Sie tasten, ob das Bein kälter ist als das andere.
Das ist auch noch ein Temperaturunterschied.
Gut, ja.
Was für Laboruntersuchen machen Sie denn?
Also ich würde gerne Blutbild und Entzündungsparameter...
Auf alle Fälle?
...besg, Lykozyten und DEDMA...
Auf alle Fälle? Sehr gut.
Ja, TBT auszuschließen.
Und wonach guckt man auch der Patient,
der im Dimm-Wassatin, und er ist Diabetiker.
Also Blutzucker.
Und die... also Vettwerte, LDH.
Genau.
Also ich würde gerne auch die Blutgerinsel überprüfen.
Also ENR.
Ah, ja, genau. Stimmt, ja.
Weil er Klopidogreel nimmt und Aspirin, ne?
Ja, gut.
Und was machen Sie für technische Untersuchungen?
Also ich führe einfach Doktionsunterschalt führen.
Also durch...
Ja, genau. Was erwarten Sie da? Was vermuten Sie?
Also ich erwarte beim Doktionsunterschalt eine Stoffung.
Ja, also Blutgerinsel, Formel.
Also ich überprüfe die Blutfliesen.
Den Blutfluss, genau.
Ja, Blutfluss.
Ja, sehr gut. Okay.
Was wäre als nächstes Verfahren nach der Duplexsonographie dann anzuwenden?
Nach dem...
Nach dem Ultraschall.
Ja, würde ich gerne...
Bildgebung.
Was für eine Bildgebung würden Sie dann machen?
Okay.
Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht...
Haben gerade schon eine CT-Angio.
Ah ja, Konkretatomographie.
Ja, bzw. eine Angiografie,
dass man also die Gefäße des Beines darstellt.
Mit einem CT.
Sehr schön.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihren unserer Suchung rauskommt.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten den Stationär aus
oder geht der nachher wieder nach Hause?
Nein, also ich nehme den Patienten den Stationär auf.
Weil er akutsch Spärzen hat, ne?
Ja, also er hat viele Risikofaktoren
und viele Vorerkrankungen.
Also er hat Nikotingeschichte.
Unbedingt müssen wir den Patienten Stationär aufnehmen
und diese... also alles.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, dann?
Beferte und Zuckerwerte.
Okay. Halten Sie mich also auf dem Laufenden,
wie es dem Patienten geht
und was Sie tatsächlich rausgefunden haben
und ob wir eine Intervention machen müssen.
Ja? Okay.
Sehr schön.
Sie haben doch eine sehr schöne Anamese hingelegt
und auch ein sehr schöner Bericht, muss man mal sagen.
Haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Wir sind sprachlich
und ganz paar Kleinigkeiten aufgefallen.
Paragutesachen,
was ich sehr schön fand,
dass Sie gesagt haben,
auf Nachfrage gab er an,
dass er keinen Fieber und keine Rötung bemerkt hat.
Ja, so. Das finde ich immer gut.
Wenn man sagt, also,
danach habe ich exkluzit gefragt
und das wurde aber vom Patienten verneint.
Das ist eine wichtige Information.
Was mir am Anfang so ein bisschen gefehlt hat,
dass Sie die Fachbegriffe nehmen.
Das hat Dr. Gündis in der Pause irgendwie kurz gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, Beinschmerzen,
Schmerzen in der unteren Extremität.
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
wie das speziell in Berlin ist,
aber das ist schon so,
dass viele Prüfer eben wertlegen,
dass sie im Arzt-Arztgespräch
die Fachtherminologie benutzen.
Manchmal sagen die auch nicht zu viel,
aber da muss man halt versuchen,
wirklich so ein bisschen rauszuhören.
Was wollen die jetzt von mir wissen?
Wollen die die Fachbegriffe haben
oder rollen die schon mit den Augen,
wenn man zu viele Fachbegriffe verwendet?
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
sprachlich bei den Anamnesefragen,
haben Sie sehr oft gefragt,
haben Sie Schmerzen.
Versuchen Sie da noch ein bisschen mehr Differenz reinzubringen.
Diejenigen, die hier schon Dauerkunden sind,
die mich immer wieder hören,
kennen das, dass ich das reklamiere
und ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass man einfach mal ein bisschen alternative formulieren kann.
Dass es nicht ganz so eintönig ist.
Und, was mir aufgefallen ist,
horchen Sie mal in Ihr Arzt-Arztgespräch rein.
Sie sagen ziemlich oft, also.
Ja, also das ist mein Problem.
Ich habe das auch bemerkt.
Ich glaube, wir machen das alle.
Wir machen das alle auch, dass wir machen zwischendurch.
Nur bei Ihnen ist es mir jetzt besonders aufgefallen.
Also, er hat gesagt,
versuche Sie das ein bisschen auszubügeln.
Es ist nicht schlimm.
Es ist mir nur so als Besonderheit aufgefallen.
Ja, es könnte nicht so sein.
Ansonsten fand ich aber wirklich,
dass Sie sowohl eine schöne, schlüssige Anamese gemacht haben.
Sie haben zwei, drei Sachen nachher noch mal nachgefragt,
nach den üblichen sozialen Dingen.
Und haben auch eine sehr schöne Schilderung gemacht.
Was ich witzig finde, Sie sind Berliner.
Denke ich mal jetzt, wenn Sie drei Jahre in Berlin sind.
Dass Sie nicht wissen, was eine Kneipe ist.
Sie haben gesagt, Kiosk.
Also, er war Gastwirt.
Gastwirt.
Das heißt, der hatte irgendwie, so wie er geschildert hat,
hatte eine Kneipe.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das, ein Lokal.
Wo es nicht viel zu essen gab, aber Kleinigkeiten gibt es da zu essen.
Und das ist eigentlich typisch für Berlin.
Auch fürs Ruhrgebiet.
Und ich glaube auch, wenn man sehr streng ist und kein Alkohol trinkt,
kennt man aber doch irgendwo so eine Kneipe in der Nachbarschaft.
Wo die Leute, so, was, was ich, sich treffen und was trinken
und ja, manchmal auch Musik hören
oder zum Beispiel, wie Fernsehe gucken, also Fußball gucken zusammen oder so.
Also, er war Gastwirt.
Aber ist das normal?
Ja, also manchmal kenne ich die Beruhte nicht.
Dann frage ich, was machen Sie genau?
Sind nicht, ich bin auch legitim.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr legitim, dass man nachfand.
Ich kann mir da drunter nichts vorstellen.
Ich erinnere, ich habe hier mal gesagt, es gibt in den Fallbeispielen,
gibt es einen Floristen.
Ja.
Was ist ein Florist?
Ja, der macht Blumenstreuse, der verkauft Blumen.
Ja, und hat also eine Ausbildung dafür.
Schmückt vielleicht irgendwie Hochzeiten aus
oder macht Begräbnisgrenze oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist ein gelernter Florist.
Ja, und na klar wissen Sie, was eine Bäckereifachangestellte ist.
Ja, das sind die Leute, die Brötchen verkaufen.
Ja, aber ja, es gibt schon viele komische Berufe,
wo man sagen muss, Rufi, muss ich mir das vorstellen.
Ja, und da gibt es natürlich auch Hinweise.
Zum Beispiel, der Gastwirt, der steht ganz viel.
Ja, der steht hinter seinem Tresen.
Ja, und der ist natürlich auch, wenn er heute 74 Jahre alt ist,
ist der Passivraucher.
Selbst wenn er selber nicht viel geraucht hat,
früher hat man in jeder Kneipe exzessiv geraucht.
Ja, und das ist ja erst seit 15 Jahren,
dass man in Deutschland nicht mehr im Restaurant rauchen darf,
dass die Leute alle vor die Haustür gehen.
Ja, da stehen die da im Winter mit Jacken draußen
und rauchen, ja, aber das war ja früher nicht so.
Ja, und das heißt, dieser Typ, der hat ganz bestimmt,
neben seinen eigenen 20 Packiers, hat er bestimmt noch ordentlich Passivrauchen
mit abgekriegt, ja, in seiner Berufstätigkeit.
Und ja, insofern ist es schon auch wichtig,
nach dem Beruf zu fragen oder eben auch die Frage bei allen Leuten,
die am Computer arbeiten, ja,
sitzen die Tätigkeit schlechte Körperhaltung,
und die haben alle irgendwo so Hals-Nackenbeschwerden, ja.
Also ich finde, das ist eine wichtige Frage,
was haben Sie gearbeitet oder was arbeiten Sie
und wie sieht Ihre Arbeit aus?
Ja, jemand zum Beispiel, der im Service arbeitet,
muss unheimlich viel rennen und schwer tragen, ja.
Die haben ganz oft Krampfadern, Friseure,
haben Sie ja oft Krampfadern, weil Sie die ganze Tag stehen, ja.
Das sind so Sachen, es ist schon eine wichtige Information.
Ja, stimmt.
Fällt mir gerade ein, ich habe keinen Friseur in allen meinen Fällen.
Muss ich mal einen erfinden, ja, demnächst gibt es mal einen Friseur.
Okay, gut.
Ich fand es eine sehr schöne Vorführung hier bei Ihnen,
das war klasse, und ich glaube,
Sie müssen vor Ihrer Prüfung keine Angst haben.
Okay.